break Dalio is the founder the world
largest and most successful hedge fund
Bridgewater
NALEO created the company in 1975 in his
two-bedroom apartment today Bridgewater
has about 1,500 employees and manages
162 billion dollars Dahle was out with
the new book called principles light and
work it describes more than 200 rules he
credits for Bridgewater success the book
is an expanded version of its original
principles which was released online in
2011 published by Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS with police to have Ray
Dalio at studio 57 welcome thank you I
want to get we're gonna talk a lot about
the book but just talk about the economy
first in terms of of how you see it and
and what has been the Trump
administration's impact on the economy
two parts the the economy is in the
ideal part of its cycle business cycles
which it means that it's not too hot and
it's not too cold and the Fed shouldn't
tighten monetary policy so that's it on
average on the on the other hand it has
a lot of debt and obligations pension
obligations health care obligations when
demographics play a role that's going to
gradually squeeze things and the most
important thing is to not talk about the
economy but to realize that there are
two different economies there's the
economy for the top forty percent let's
say and then there's economy for the
bottom and so when we think about the
Trump presidency we're dealing with the
conflict or the dilemmas this divergence
is between those two economies and the
populism that that is then bringing
forward to have his election and then
with that we have to deal with those two
economies that's the biggest issue of
our time I think but is it more about
the business cycle than it is about
administration's either legislative or
regulatory decisions the legislative
decisions are and the regulatory
decisions are matters to change create
that divergence but in other words that
population that is the bottom 60% has
not had economic growth they're the
majority they have not had eken
growth they have a rising death rate
from opiates and heroin suicides they
have their own particular challenges and
this this economy is now in one way or
another about dealing with those two
different economies and also technology
as technology is entering into this so
that it's replacing jobs in other words
productivity it's also replacing jobs in
creating two different economies this is
the most important economic issue of our
time that is why we have populism with
that populism produces a question of how
conflict is dealt with we have a gap
between those the haves and have-nots
and we have those types of conflict that
is the most important thing of the
presidency and it's not just the US
presidency it's a world phenomenon
you'll talk about it later in Europe
just to put a finer point on that you
because the wealth gap is the largest in
this country since the 1920s that's
right the period right now is very
similar to 1937 if you go back in 1937
1929 32 like 2008 we had a debt problem
they interest rates went to zero they
printed a lot of money bought a lot of
financial assets and that rose and just
as you point out in 1937 we were at a
similar point and that 1937 we had we
had a wealth gap large wealth gap and we
also had a Federal Reserve that began to
tighten monetary policy so let's talk
about principles book I'm sitting have
you heard of this book principle is a
great line of how you operate because
you talk about radical truth and radical
transparency reminds me of the line from
the movie where they go you can't handle
the truth but you're saying it's
important that you tell the truth even
though it may hurt people's feelings
it's essential in a good work
environment yeah the look we have to
start with what's reality it's right we
have to start with what truth is there
are three things in order to be
successful those three things are that
you have to lay your honest thoughts on
the table can you do that
lay your honest thoughts on the table
mm-hmm second you have to have
thoughtful disagreement
between people who disagree they'd have
to know how to work those things through
so that they all learn and then third to
be able to go beyond those disagreements
in an idea meritocratic way it's all
about making better decisions all right
you said the key ingredients to making a
good decision and you've got two
principles that you operate when it
comes time to making a good decision so
when you which ones do you think
open-minded yes number one you have to
be a but that's one of your key
principles well I think what you're
referring to I think that there we go in
your blinds there are the two barriers
right the two barriers like why can't we
be radically transparent and radically
open with each other to get at what's
true and work ourselves through there
are two barriers and those two barriers
are there's an ego barrier our brains
are programmed in a certain way having
to do with our amygdala that triggers
these reactions and so on and also we
develop the bad habits that we can hear
like you say we can't handle the truth
yeah and if you can do that if you it's
a matter of habit and in the book I
explain how we actually do that and this
has been the key to our success being
able to be that way so radically open
minded and then through that getting
around also that blind spot area because
nobody themselves actually sees the
picture the same way that's right there
are big picture thinkers there are
detailed thinkers we need them all and
they all see everything very differently
and when you can bring that into focus
so that you can see in three dimensions
or multi dimensions and then know how to
take advantage of all that and go beyond
it it's very powerful
the thing about this book it's great
even if you're not in business I'll just
say that there's lessons here for a lot
of people to learn from what you're
telling us Ray Dalio we thank you
principals is on sale tomorrow wherever
you like to buy your books